These days, it can be tough keeping track
of everything that's going on in the MCU.
But maybe that's not such a bad thing
— after all, it just means more to look
forward to. Here are the most exciting
Marvel projects coming over the horizon.
WandaVision is among the more intriguing of
Marvel's Disney+ series. Overseen by Captain
Marvel and Black Widow screenwriter Jac Schaeffer,
the show features the reunion of — you guessed it
— Wanda Maximoff and Vision. Of course, everyone's
favorite robot boyfriend was looking just a tad
bit dead the last time he appeared, which begs
the question: just how is he making his return?
Well, it seems almost certain at this
point that WandaVision takes place at
least partly within an alternate reality,
especially given that the series will tie
into the events of Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness. The first trailer
for WandaVision seems to confirm that the show
will venture to a number of different realities,
each set in a different decade and based
around a different style of American sitcom.
The series will also bring back
Kat Dennings as Darcy Lewis,
as well as Randall Park as Jimmy Woo.
MCU newcomer Kathryn Hahn is taking on
the role of Wanda and Vision's nosy neighbor
Agnes, while Teyonah Parris will be playing
a grown-up version of Monica Rambeau , who
was last seen as a child in Captain Marvel.
Thankfully, It won't be a terribly long wait to
discover how all of these seemingly disparate
characters will come together — WandaVision
was originally slated to debut on Disney+
sometime in the spring of next year, but the
release date has been moved up to January 15th.
The so-called Sony Universe of Marvel
Characters was born of Sony Pictures'
deal with Marvel Studios, which allowed Marvel to
integrate Spider-Man into the MCU. In exchange,
Sony continues to produce the webhead's
MCU-set solo outings, and also has free
rein to develop its own universe based
on ancillary Spider-Man characters.
This universe's inaugural effort, 2018's Venom,
cleaned up at the box office, while satisfying
fans of the character left cold by the last
time the character appeared in a feature film.
"Do you remember? Do you
remember what you did to me?"
After Venom's unexpected success, Sony was
quick to fast-track another Spidey-related
property — one that has been gestating since
2017. This would be Morbius, based on the "living
vampire" and frequent Spider-Man nemesis who first
appeared in the pages of Marvel comics in 1971.
The flick will star Jared Leto as Dr. Michael
Morbius, a brilliant biochemist whose attempts to
cure his own potentially fatal blood disease with
an experimental treatment go predictably awry,
transforming him into a superpowered vampire.
Daniel Espinosa directs from a script by Lost
in Space co-creators Matt Sazama and Burk
Sharpless. Of course, whether Morbius can
match Venom's runaway success has yet to be seen
— but we'll know for sure on March 19th, 2021.
Marvel has been promising a standalone
movie for Natasha Romanoff for years,
and now, on May 7th 2021, it's finally happening —
with Black Widow, in which Scarlett Johansson will
reprise the role of the superspy Avenger
for what will likely be the last time.
The prequel is set in the period between Captain
America: Civil War and Avengers: Infinity War,
but will likely also flash back to the time before
Romanoff's recruitment by S.H.I.E.L.D. According
to director Cate Shortland, the movie will
find Romanoff in a dark place. Shortland says:
"In this film we get to understand her past
and put the pieces of herself
together and come out a whole person."
Much of the action will take place overseas, and
yes, it seems fans will finally get to find out
just what went down in Budapest. Johansson's
co-stars include Florence Pugh and Rachel
Weisz , who will appear as operatives who have
undergone the same Red Room training that honed
Romanoff's deadly skills. Also starring is David
Harbour, who will portray Alexei Shostakov ,
a.k.a. the Red Guardian, Russia's answer to
Captain America. Rounding out the cast will be
O-T Fagbenle as Marcus, an underworld "fixer," and
Ray Winstone, whose role is currently undisclosed.
The debut for the MCU's first
Asian hero Shang-Chi was teased
in late 2018 — but until the full
title was revealed in July 2019,
the particularly exciting involvement of the
movie's iconic villain had only been rumored.
Yes, on July 9th 2021, Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings will see the Master of Kung Fu
face off against the Mandarin — the classic
Iron Man villain who notoriously didn't
feature in Iron Man 3. As the title suggests,
the Ten Rings, the terrorist organization who
kidnapped Tony Stark in Iron Man, will also
figure prominently into the on-screen origin
of Shang-Chi — who is arguably the finest
unarmed combatant in the Marvel universe.
Destin Daniel Cretton has been tapped to
direct, with Chinese-Canadian actor Simu
Liu holding down the title role. Also confirmed to
be starring are Awkwafina in an undisclosed role,
as well as the legendary Chinese actor
Tony Leung as the Mandarin himself.
Another long-rumored project to finally
be confirmed at Comic-Con in 2019 was
the Disney+ series The Falcon and the
Winter Soldier, which will see Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan reprising their
roles of Steve Rogers' two best buddies.
It seems that Sam Wilson may have a bit of
reconciling to do between his old heroic
identity and the new identity bequeathed to him
by Rogers himself at the conclusion of Avengers:
Endgame. Exact plot details have so far been kept
under wraps, but we do know one thing for sure:
the six-episode series will see the return
of Zemo, the man who goaded the Avengers into
the titular conflict of Captain America: Civil
War, and he'll even be sporting his distinctive
purple mask from the comics. The Handmaid's Tale
director Kari Skogland will helm every episode,
with writing duties being handled by Empire's
Malcolm Spellman and John Wick's Derek Kolstad .
Here's a project that should ring all
kinds of nostalgia bells for longtime
Marvel Comics readers. What If? is an
alternate universe anthology series
which has run in various formats since
1977, exploring how events may have
unfolded if crucial moments in the mainstream
Marvel timeline had played out differently.
It allows readers to consider scenarios
both intriguing and unthinkable, and what
it did for the comics, the Disney+ animated
series What If? intends to do for the MCU.
Like its comic-book counterpart, What
If? will have an anthology format,
with each episode tackling one specific moment
in the MCU timeline. Disney's "Expanding the
Universe" featurette on Disney+ confirmed the
premise of several of the series' episodes,
including "What if Peggy Carter had
taken the super soldier serum?",
"What if T'Challa was Star Lord?", and
"What if Captain America was a zombie?"
The Marvel Studios Comic-Con panel revealed
an impressive line-up of MCU talent set to
lend their voices, with many of the films'
biggest stars set to reprise their roles.
They will be joined by Jeffrey Wright in the
central role of Uatu the Watcher, whose job is
to watch over the multiverse, and who will act
as a sort of host, tying each episode together.
At the panel, Wright teased the practically
limitless possibilities the series might offer.
"We'll see where we take it.
We can take it anywhere."
Given the fact that it kicked off a
universe of Spider-Man characters which
probably won't actually feature Spider-Man, the
success of Sony's Venom was a bit of a shock.
Anchored by Tom Hardy's completely bonkers
performance, the film cleaned up at the
worldwide box office to the tune of $855 million
dollars, making a sequel pretty much obligatory.
Of course, having learned a few tricks from Marvel
Studios, Sony made sure to go ahead and set one
up in advance, with a post-credits scene featuring
Woody Harrelson as Cletus Kasady, the psychopathic
serial killer who will go on to become Carnage,
the Venom symbiote's terrifying offspring.
One stumbling block the sequel faced was the
departure of Venom director Ruben Fleischer,
who had his hands full with the long-awaited
follow-up to his 2009 classic Zombieland. Now,
motion capture legend Andy Serkis has stepped up
to the helm, with original scribe Kelly Marcel
already drafting a screenplay, and Hardy set
to return along with co-star Michelle Williams.
Plot details are sketchy right
now, but one thing is certain:
just as Kasady promised in that
stinger, there's gonna be, well…
Carnage. Indeed, Variety confirmed
what everyone expected in January 2019:
that Harrelson's homicidal symbiote will be the
movie's main villain. Venom: Let There Be Carnage
was expected to hit theaters on October 2nd, 2020,
but was later moved to a summer 2021 release.
Among the first batch of Marvel Disney+ series
is Loki, which sees Tom Hiddleston returning to
portray the beloved trickster once more. While
our version of the character met a grim end in
the brutal opening sequence of Avengers: Infinity
War, the series will follow the 2012 version of
Loki who disappeared with the Tesseract during
the bungled time heist in Avengers: Endgame.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, the series
will follow Loki as he "pops up throughout human
history as an unlikely influencer on historical
events." The project has scored a showrunner who
should know his way around this kind of material,
too: Michael Waldron , who has worked as a writer
on Adult Swim's Rick and Morty and will be
credited as creator and executive producer,
in addition to writing the pilot.
Meanwhile, Kate Herron mwill direct.
Joining Hiddleston will be
fellow cast members Owen Wilson,
Sophia Di Martino , Gugu Mbatha-Raw, and Richard
E. Grant — all in undisclosed roles. That said,
Wilson is taking on the role
of a man called Mr. Mobius,
while Richard E. Grant is thought to be playing
an older, alternate version of Loki himself.
Rounding out the first round of
Disney+ limited series will be Hawkeye,
which will see Jeremy Renner reprise his
role as the legendary wisecracking archer.
During 2019's San Diego Comic-Con,
Marvel debuted the series' logo,
as well as the confirmation of a long-standing
rumor: that the series will see the debut of
Kate Bishop, the young protege who eventually
takes up the mantle of Hawkeye in the comics.
The series is confirmed to take place after the
events of Avengers: Endgame, so it'll likely
see Clint Barton adjusting to a world in which
his beloved family has returned from the Snap,
and his trusted ally Natasha Romanoff is no
more. While no plot details were announced,
Renner did share one little tidbit with
the Comic-Con crowd, which suggests that
Barton's mentorship of Bishop will be key
to the series' narrative. Renner joked:
"I get to teach someone else how to
be a superhero without superpowers."
"What I get to do in the show
ultimately is shepherd an amazing
character to be ultimately
probably a better version of me."
Fans have been clamoring for Kate Bishop's story
to make its way to the screen for some time,
but they'll have to wait a bit
longer to see it come to fruition:
Hawkeye is scheduled to debut
on Disney+ in the fall of 2021.
In 2019, Marvel Studios opened
their Comic-Con panel with Eternals,
an interesting if lesser-known property which
should help anchor the cosmic side of the MCU.
The titular race of superpowered beings
were created eons ago by the Celestials
in order to defend the Earth from
their polar opposites, the Deviants.
The Eternals were the brainchild
of the great Jack Kirby,
who created the comic in the mid-'70s
after his run on New Gods at DC.
Marvel head honcho Kevin Feige has teased that
Eternals’ story may span "tens of thousands of
years," telling an epic story of the kind we
haven't yet seen in the MCU. And the movie,
which will be directed by The Rider's Chloe
Zhao, has assembled a suitably epic cast.
Eternals will star Richard Madden as Ikaris ,
a first-generation Eternal and leader of the
movie's team of heroes. Alongside him will be
Angelina Jolie as Thena, Gemma Chan as Sersi,
and Barry Keoghan as the
villainous Eternal, Druig.
Meanwhile, Kumail Nanjiani will appear as
Kingo, a samurai and Bollywood movie star,
Lauren Ridloff will play a gender-swapped version
of Makkari , a tinkerer and engineer, and Brian
Tyree Henry is Phastos , a master weapons
maker who nevertheless prefers not to fight.
Salma Hayek will play Ajak , another
gender-swapper character, while Lia
McHugh features as the trickster Sprite.
It's a heck of a cast, and although the
Eternals may not be A-list Marvel characters,
there's a good chance this will become one of
the studio's biggest properties. Eternals
is due for release on February 12th, 2021.
For just over a month during the summer of
2019, Spider-Man fans were left broken-hearted
at the news that talks between Disney
and Sony Pictures had broken down,
and their shared custody agreement
over Spider-Man had come to an end.
But then, in late September, the news broke that
the two studios had finally decided to play nice.
A new deal was struck which will allow
Marvel Studios to co-produce at least
one more Spider-Man film, and also
feature the character in an additional,
as-yet undisclosed Marvel Studios picture. It's
been speculated that Marvel's third Spider-Man
movie will essentially be used to write the
wall-crawler out of the MCU in preparation for
a move to Sony's own Spider-Verse, but the reality
could be a lot more complex... and a lot weirder.
When J.K. Simmons reprised his role as J. Jonah
Jameson from Sam Raimi's Spider-Man trilogy in the
end credits of Spider-Man: Far From Home, everyone
suspected something strange was afoot in the MCU.
Now, things are set to get even odder, as Marvel
revealed in October 2020 that Spider-Man 3 would
pull in yet another character from a previous
unrelated Spider-film — with the announcement
that Jamie Foxx would be returning as Electro,
his character from The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
Since then, the return of many classic villains
and alternate Spider-Men have been confirmed.
While Far From Home teased at a multiverse that
ultimately turned out to be a ruse perpetuated
by Mysterio, Simmons' and now Foxx's inclusion
seem to suggest the real deal is on the way:
a fully-fledged multiverse that brings together
all of the past iterations of Spider-Man.
We'll learn more about how Marvel's
various Spider-Verses fit together when
Spider-Man 3 hits theaters on December 17th, 2021.
Given the fantastic character arc that
unravelled over his last several appearances,
speculation had been running high for some time
that Thor would be the first Avenger
to land himself a fourth solo film.
"Because that's what -"
"Because that's what heroes do."
In July 2019, Marvel finally
confirmed this was the case,
with Thor: Ragnarok's Taika Waititi returning
to direct. But that wasn't all Marvel announced.
Hitting theatres on February 11th 2022, Thor:
Love and Thunder will see the return of Natalie
Portman's Jane Foster, who will follow in her
character's recent comic book footsteps by
picking up Mjolnir to become Thor herself. Tessa
Thompson will also return as Valkyrie , and Kevin
Feige has confirmed that this time around, it will
be made explicit that the character is bisexual,
a first for a major character in an MCU
film. It has also been all-but-confirmed
that the Guardians of the Galaxy will
be making an appearance in the movie,
and that the main villain will be played by none
other than Dark Knight alumnus Christian Bale.
With all that in mind, it's hard not to believe
that Marvel will be expecting Love and Thunder
to be one of their biggest and most popular Phase
4 releases. Frankly, who could argue otherwise?
The sequel to 2016's Doctor Strange has been
in development since before that flick even hit
theaters, and last year Marvel announced some new
details about the project. Namely, that it would
be titled Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness, that it would co-star Elizabeth
Olsen as Wanda Maximoff, and that it would be
directly influenced by the events of WandaVision.
The Marvel faithful were suitably psyched —
but then disaster struck. In January 2020,
it was announced that the movie's director,
Scott Derrickson, had left the picture due
to creative differences with Marvel Studios.
Fortunately, fans didn't have to despair for
long — because Marvel promptly reached into
its hat and pulled out one heck of a rabbit.
Taking over the picture will be none other
than Sam Raimi, who not only gave us one
of the greatest horror-comedies of all time, but
also helped set the entire template for the modern
superhero genre with his Spider-Man trilogy. The
second film of that trilogy, 2004's Spider-Man 2,
is to this day widely considered to be
among the very best comic book movies
ever made — and for the sheer insanity
promised by the Strange sequel's title,
the director seems like an absolutely
perfect fit for the role. Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness
releases on March 25th, 2022.
After the tremendous success
of 2018's Black Panther,
a sequel seemed like a foregone conclusion.
And sure enough, in the fall of 2018,
The Hollywood Reporter reported that
Black Panther 2 was officially happening,
with original writer-director Ryan Coogler
returning to write and direct the sequel,
and celebrated star Chadwick Boseman expected
to reprise his role as King T'Challa.
Tragically, however, in August 2020, Boseman
passed away following a four-year struggle with
cancer. The news came as a shock to Boseman's
fans and colleagues alike, as the actor had
kept his condition and treatment quiet, even as he
continued to work. Following the news of Boseman's
passing, Marvel declined to speculate on the
future of the Black Panther franchise, choosing
instead to grieve the heartbreaking and shocking
loss of one of the world's brightest stars.
While it's safe to assume Black Panther 2 is still
happening, there's no knowing right now when that
will be, or what form the story will take. While
some have speculated that his on-screen sister
Shuri may take up the Black Panther mantle, as she
does in the comics, the pain of Boseman's passing
is still too fresh for anyone to publicly
commit to a direction for the franchise.
One thing that is certain, however, is that
whenever Black Panther 2 does make its way to
the screen, both the story and its characters
will find a suitable way to honor their king.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.